Okay guys, we are going to discuss HTML or
Hypertext Markup Language. HTML documents are the, the heart
of the Web. The Web is basically made up
of these documents that can do a number of
things. So HTML is made up of text content,
which is what you see. It's made up of
markup3 which is what that content looks like or
how it's arranged. It's made up of references to
other documents, like images and videos. You may have something that looks
like this and you've got some text and you'll have a, you
know, an image on your page. Or like the page you're looking
at now, which has got a video in the middle of it. You
know, the page you're looking at now is made up of HTML
and it's got references to a big fat video. And it can
be made up of links to other pages. And, I'm sure you're
very familiar with what links are and how they're used. Let's let's play
around with HTML a little bit. This is a
simple HTML editor we have so we can play
with things and test them out. You can follow
along by either, I think there should be a
link in the course notes, or you can also go to www.udacity.com/html.playground.
And that should get you this this little
page where you can kind of experiment a little bit. This is kind of a, a fake
little test browser. So, the first thing I'd like
to show you is that if we have just some
blank text. If we were to render this as HTML,
it would look the same. Plain text is plain text
in HTML, for the most part. But if we want
to make the text look different, we need to use
something called markup, which is one of the other facets
of HTML. And let's learn a little bit about markup.